meanwhile the European Union has agreed
on a new 18 billion Euro Aid package for
Ukraine at a summit in Brussels leaders
also Drew up their ninth round of
sanctions against Russia travel bans and
asset freezes are being extended
prime minister arrived at the summit
threatening to derail the whole thing on
the table an 18 billion Euro Aid package
for Ukraine Mateus from marivetsky was
unhappy over several other measures but
compromises were made every sink was
approved macro financial assistance
money for Hungary and minimal taxation
for a company so-called pillar the
second pillar so there is no need to
commend the process I think the result
is most important the EU was able to
create a price cap for Russian oil
globally last month to try to stop
Moscow from profiteering from soaring
Energy prices
but this time the leaders in Brussels
were only able to pass on plans for a
similar cap on gas to energy ministers
meeting next week
officials did rubber stamp a ninth set
of sanctions on Moscow which include
blacklisting nearly 200 more people and
banning investments in Russia's mining
industry
the Russian strategy of destroying
Ukraine's infrastructure and exposing
its citizens to a brutally cold winter
may not and will not succeed
the summit was overshadowed by a
corruption Scandal engulfing the
European Parliament one of its vice
presidents accused of taking money from
Qatar for favors here a promise to root
out corruption as of today I am putting
together
a wide ranging reform package
to be ready in the new year
this will include the strengthening of
the parliament's whistleblower
Protection Systems
a ban on all unofficial friendships
groups
a review of the policing of our code
of conduct rules
and a complete and in-depth look of how
we interact
with third countries the EU is winding
down its business for the holidays but
before leaving leaders decided tackling
the migration crisis in southern Europe
will be their priority when they get
together again in the new year
DW special correspondent Aya Ibrahim is
in Brussels she's been covering that
Summit for us
I've heard in that report EU is imposing
further sanctions on Russia tell us more
well we don't have the full details of
that sanctions package yet but it does
seem to be a lot more targeted we're
told that around 200 Russian and
military officials are set to be
targeted by this with travel bans and
acid freezes but we don't have the full
details yet on that package
okay so as we wait on that uh let's look
at Ukraine that's been of course a
dominant topic for months for nearly 10
months now the eu's been providing
massive support to Ukraine how much of a
strain higher is that putting on unity
in the block
well if you talk to European leaders all
of them will reaffirm their support for
Ukraine but when you look at the details
of their decisions that's where you see
some cracks in that Unity if you will
um we saw it yesterday Belgium and the
Netherlands for example on the sidelines
of the conference seeking exemptions on
Russian
Imports of fertilizers
um obviously that is a sign that you
know the economic strain of these
sanctions is perhaps starting to show in
these countries there's also that 18
billion Euro eight package that you
mentioned earlier that itself was a
difficult one to get through I mean
initially Hungary had vetoed that
package and it did that because the
European Union was withholding recovery
funds from Hungary because Hungary was
not complying with rule of law Clauses
of the European Union now a compromise
was reached on that and some funds it
has been agreed that some funds will be
released to Hungary in exchange for its
approval of the that package but then
after that Poland came around and said
wow I mean if Hungary can you know get
its way and get something that it wants
out of the European Union by blocking
this package well maybe we can get
something out of it as well and so you
do see there that there is a real danger
that political interest of individual
countries can get in the way of action
when it comes to that solidarity but
definitely when you speak to leaders
they'll tell you they have a united
front
okay there's a lot on the agenda there
for this last Summit of the year for the
EU uh trade among there have been
serious trade tensions between the EU
and the U.S was there any movement on
that
right I mean the United States the Biden
Administration has been taking recent
action to uh prop up the economy we're
talking about the inflation reduction
act which uh it essentially encourages
American companies to buy American it
would encourage them with uh subsidies
uh and tax breaks in that sense and that
obviously you know if you're sitting in
Berlin and you're thinking okay well is
are my car parts going to be now
competitive for the United States to
import so that's caused a lot of concern
here in Brussels for the European Union
as a whole and yesterday the European
commission has now been asked to come up
with concrete proposals on how to
counter the effects of the IRA
oh yeah thank you very much our special
correspondent Aya Ibrahim and Brussels